do you think Trump derangement syndrome
is a medical condition
um also is there such thing as uh Biden
derangement syndrome what I mean by that
I said it's a it's a funny kind of
question but why are people so deeply
outraged
seemingly Beyond Reason at their hatred
or support on Donald Trump but hatred in
particular I've seen a lot of friends
and people I respect
like lose their mind completely yeah
so I'm not sure it's a medical condition
or not because I'm not a medical doctor
so I you know my kids say I'm the wrong
guy in the doctor I'm I'm a doctor so
let me take you from here no uh P the
fact that you get the doctor sign after
getting a PhD is a ridiculous hilarity
to me hilarious ridiculous so as as the
wrong kind of doctor I'll say I'm not
going to comment on whether it's a
medical condition but I do think you're
on to something
um I think there is a way in which
um these men
become
touchstones of anger and there's all
kinds of anger and anxiety that people
have
and I've seen this in other historical
periods you you Center it on one person
uh in a way that's John Wilkes Booth in
Lincoln
he actually didn't have a personal beef
with Lincoln
it was that all the things he feared
were were manifest uh in that and I
think that's an old story and then it's
made worse by social media
and the way we're bombarded and it's
it's like
it becomes a drug I mean they're people
I know who hate Trump or Biden so much
and just watch them it's not that they
don't watch them it's that they do watch
them right and it's just sort of and it
triggers you and and you get hateful and
then you feel like you've done something
by shouting out your hate or typing in
and and so I don't know if it's a
derangement syndrome I think it's a it's
a way in which our energy gets channeled
and expressed in totally useless ways